la situation est compliquée notamment
pour beaucoup de sociétés audiovisuelles
comme la mienne en gaz at heart avec un
tournage
donc forcément c'est compliqué de faire
des films quand ya pas de tournage mais
on profite de ce temps avec mes acier
que des actifs travaillent pour pour
écrire a notamment des nouveaux projets
des nouveaux scénarios pour faire du
montage sur des projets existants voilà
on ne trouve comme le moyen de continuer
à faire des choses même si c'est vrai
qu'en terme de tournage a pour l'instant
on est comme tout le monde confiné chez
nous et attendre de voir comment les
choses vont évoluer pour qu'on puisse à
travailler